hallo mein name ist lücken bei der
lieben zuschauer ich habe ja bereits vor
zwei wochen auf japanische werbung
reagiert
die verschiedenen tv werbungen auf die
ich da reagiert habe waren auf jeden
fall hart komisch und heute wird es mich
gerade besser eigentlich wenn ihr seht
bereits im titel eingeblendet meine
lieben freunde wir schauen uns heute
gemeinsam verboten
tv werbungen an das hier ist die erste
werbung
ihr seht schon die ist im 4 3-format
glaube ich also diese auf jeden fall
schon ein bisschen älter
es ist ein volkswagen polo glaube ich
und er fährt jetzt irgendwo hin
parkt vor einem café oder ein werbe
freundlichkeit holos molotov
darf man eigentlich gar nicht klatschen
dass selbst die nächste werbung
[Musik]
okay okay es hieß doch statt die werbung
jetzt geht einmal darum dass der typ
eine blaupunkt anlage in seinem auto
hatte und die
[Musik]
das ist ja wer advantage in your card
wirklich es geht werbung gerade im tv
ich guck zwar kein fernsehen aber ich
wette dass es solche werbung gibt die
auf jeden fall freizügiger und mehr + 18
sind als hier zwei stofftiere auf der
rücksitzbank beziehen wir sehen im
kofferraum eines autos die da also ich
weiss nicht hättet ihr diese werbung
verboten ich hätte mir gedacht ethiker
die ist lustig die cockpits wert sehen
das hier ist die nächste werbung
es geht um doritos also es geht um chips
es ist eine frau freizügig angezogen mit
einem kleid die die treppe hochgeht hier
ist eine andere frau die macht sich die
haare und hier sitzt sie mit dem schwarz
oder die gleiche frau okay sie deckt
sich auf jeden fall ein mit den chips
weiter konnten
warum
ist
durch die hier geht es tatsächlich
wieder um die realos und zwar sitzt dort
ein typ auf einer bank und eine frau job
dran vorbei und schickt jetzt dass er
die realos hat und sie sie sind leer
jetzt und jetzt sitze hier und jetzt
wieder da und ist die frau kommt wieder
angelaufen
[Musik]
dieses jahr wird gewissen anderen level
ich meine aber dass ich genau diese
werbung im fernsehen mal gesehen habe
oder
wir haben uns auch schon 67 jahre alt
steht hier waren allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten werbung und zwar
ist das ja eine person die auf einmal
kommt ein auto okay findet petra co
darunter steht der spruch get some nazi
der hintergrund der werbung ist dass
dieser typ da oben auf seinem panzer
ähnlichen gefährt keine ahnung was mit
seinem maschinengewehr dass es ihn ab
fakt dass seine person also ein mann
einfach nur normal wort und nicht
schnell sprintet und das findet er nicht
männlich genug von daher sagte haye
besorg dir ein paar nüsse und chips mit
hass auf ihn und ich finde einfach
wirklich dass es unsere heutige zeit
ausmacht dass jeder so sein kann wie er
will also auch diese ganze lgbt kyu
bewegung und so weiter und so fort finde
ich mich geschlagen da kann ich auf
jeden fall verstehen dass die werbung da
nicht so gut ins tv gepasst hätte und
auch vielleicht für den einen oder
anderen skandal gesorgt hat machen
allerdings direkt weiter mit der
nächsten wer bei uns was ihr ein
fotograf mit einem freizügig angezogenen
model
die haben ein fotoshooting und dahinter
steht
einer der in serie auch okay erlaubt ihr
okay menschen ziemlich abstoßend dass
die habe ich doch auch im tv gesehen
oder bin ich blöd und wer allerdings nur
meine damen und herren zum mittlerweile
schon letzten verbotenen tv werbung die
wir uns heute gemeinsam anschauen werden
in diesem action video hier und zwar ist
eine werbung von dem unternehmen
skittles ich mag es geht jetzt
eigentlich also ich würde sagen wir
schauen uns mal die werbung an
[Musik]
ich kann schon verstehen
ok ok cherie u
warum ist die verboten worden
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
alles auch beenden meine lieben freunde
wenn euch meine reaktion auf einige
verbotene tv werbungen gefallen hat dann
hast du nicht mal einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da und schreibt mir
bitte auch nach unten in die kommentare
ob er eventuell einige der werbung sogar
erlaubt hätte also wenn ihr darüber
entscheiden dürfte haye kommt diese
werbung ins fernsehen ja oder nein was
hättet ihr eventuell erlaubt und was er
dir definitiv verboten 90 global auf
verbotene tv werbungen oder irgendwelche
komischen tv werbungen oder eventuell
doch sogar noch mal auf der panische
werbung reagieren soll
dann abonniert main kanal es wird mir
auf jeden fall zeigen ihr habt bock
drauf und falschen abonnent sind dann
klickt er auf die glocke denn dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
ich ein neues video la der wahnsinn
[Musik]